first was brulee is on the campaign
trail would you like a leaflet we're
from the Phoenicians I'll enjoy reading
it
a leaflet from the National Front no
thanks
some booksellers don't know how to read
Callay belongs to Frances far-right
National Front party and as running as a
candidate in the northeastern city of
mitts we're heading towards a camp for
asylum seekers or pseudo asylum seekers
who have arrived in met they're camped
out close to the buildings of the
authorities responsible for processing
their claims she believes these
immigrants need to be deported and
claims the vast majority of them are
only in the country to sponge off the
welfare system these people are applying
for political asylum when in reality at
least 85% of them are in fact economic
migrants who come to France because they
know they'll get social welfare they all
have a chance of getting residency
permits here she blames Europe for
France's problems and says her party
offers the solution she wants France to
leave the Schengen Agreement and
reintroduce border controls for nathalie
de oliveira that idea is absurd she's
the socialist candidate for Metz and the
city's deputy mayor that would mean
closing the border to Luxembourg to
where some 100,000 locals commute daily
her own parents are from Portugal they
came to France with the hope of a better
future the promise you know is lying
their slogans are dangerous this is not
progress it sets us back decades the
socialist candidate points out that many
of the projects in the area have been
funded by the European Union effect
often ignored by the far-right this is
the impact of the European Union here we
have a brand new opto electronic
research center equipped with the most
advanced technology it consists of 550
square meters of laboratories
and the same amount of office space it
was funded with 3.6 million euros from
the European Union Hawk despite that
there's growing support for the
far-right in eastern France in part out
of protest against socialist president
Francois Hollande one of the biggest
issues for people here is the demise of
the steel industry they had pinned their
hopes on him to protect the remaining
manufacturing plants instead they're
being bombarded with headlines about his
love life as a result the National Front
did well in local elections in
neighboring Island the far-right party
is already in power the former trade
unionist heard far-right politician
Fabian Engelmann became the town's mayor
in April I own jazz partner towns in
Luxembourg and Belgium immediately
distanced themselves but that's done
little to dent the new mayor's
confidence mayor just wanted to make a
statement and make himself come across
as a kind of revolutionary who wants
nothing to do with the full Nacional
avec but there was no real connection to
speak up between the two partner towns
anyway the mayor believes France would
be better off without the EU people
constantly claim that Europe has brought
peace that seems to be the magic word
but instead we're seeing the middle
class reduced to nothing unemployment is
rampant everything has become more
expensive and people can no longer pay
their bills but even here not everyone
is buying the idea that things used to
be better here we've seen wars in 1870
1914 and 1944 and father foot now our
relationship with our European neighbors
is much better I think it's important
for that to continue that's important to
me I'm terribly bothered by what's
happened in Ione's the Nazis are back
and this time they're among us
girl unless you have yen mission
Francois Molay and party leader marine
lepen reject any Nazi comparisons they
say their fight against the so called
Islamization of society is justified by
the constitutionally enshrined
separation of church and state and that
anti-semitism is not an issue within the
party they want to reintroduce the
French franc the old currency and
introduce import duty on foreign goods
they're convinced these policies will
benefit the economy this store sells
kitchen appliances the owner makes sure
that most of the products he sells here
are French we welcome this kind of
economic patriotism we want people to
buy French goods and not some low
quality products which have been
manufactured on some corner of the earth
we have the means to offer French
consumers what they want many people
blame globalization for the economic
crisis for some a strictly national
solution is an attractive prospect by
simply turning back the clock the
far-right seeks to harvest more
victories at the upcoming European
elections